[Music]
this is a dream come true Big Bang star
Kaley cuoco's that I do to cook style
[Music]
it's gonna be very special very
emotional and all the things that are
important to us there will be no animals
left behind every animal we have will be
part of it
[Music]
Kaylie did not lie
her dogs walk down the aisle just before
she did the 32 year old bride who got
last-minute touches in the feed room of
the horse stable for a custom Reem Acra
lace gown with a matching cape the vows
well those were handwritten and
exchanged and from the giant horseshoe
made of champagne feather grass and
flowers her sister Brianna officiated
the I Do's
[Music]
[Music]
for the reception Kaylee changed into
this lace jumpsuit by Tadashi Shoji her
up dude turned into this party ponytail
Kaylee and Carl the son of a software
billionaire got their groove on guests
including Kaylee's Big Bang Theory
co-stars Mayim Bialik and her
ex-boyfriend Johnny Galecki were treated
to a huge celebration the first dance
was projected on the tenth ceiling the
1920s themed party included a fire-eater
people on stilts cigarette girls with
mints and chocolate cigars even a juice
bar for touch-ups oh my god everything
from the veggie burgers to the wedding
favor whiskey bottles had the KC squared
logo a source tells us Kayleigh quote
felt beautiful it was perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]